hi I'm Eric Boston spider-man far from
home was the love letter to Marvel fans
to cheer us up from the sob fest of
Avengers endgame with lots of laughs and
a lot of wheat what to twist after twist
but the mini mr. X so far from home were
part of its elaborate design so join me
as i rewatch and break down this
spider-man film scene by Steen to
explore its deeper meaning and the many
Easter eggs that director John Watts it
throughout this film spoiler warning
haven't seen it yet and let's get
started okay we open in the Mexican
desert as Nick Fury in Maria Hill Drive
up to the ruins of the town of extinct
Oh to investigate a cyclone that locals
described as having a face there they
meet Quintin Beck Jake Gyllenhaal now it
comes to no surprise to any spider-man
fan that Mysterio is actually the
villain of the story but the exact
nature of his plan is fairly well
disguised although of course there are
plenty of clues that Beck's battles with
these elemental monsters are false mr. X
and the first shows up right here the
license plate of the car beside Furion
Hill shows the number 463 both in this
movie and in spider-man homecoming John
watts is obsessed with hiding Easter
eggs in license plates including a
recently revealed however the duck
reference at homecoming that I spent way
too much time fighting for 6-3 is most
likely a reference to the amazing
spider-man number 4 which came out in
1963 which was the introduction of the
villain Sandman but this sand monster
that they're fighting is not Flint Marko
Sandman it's what Beck later describes
as an elemental so including this
deliberate Sandman reference on the
plate is a deliberate misdirect by the
director he's telling us eagle-eyed
viewers hey good job you think you found
the truth but that truth is hi you
saying trust nothing in this movie
before I continued thank you to Marvel
collect bye tops for sponsoring this
breakdown Marvel collect is a digital
trading card app free to download free
to play with a vast collection of cards
from spider-man
Avengers guardians of the galaxy x-men
and more you can download Marvel
collects from the iTunes App Store or
Google Play Store worldwide or use our
download link in the description below
with marvel collect you can collect
trade and connect with a global
community of Marvel fans and love all
these cards feature content from both
the current cinematic universe of Marvel
and the classic Marvel Comics so you can
celebrate the release of spider-man far
from home with a card of Peter Parker
swinging through the Venice canals or a
card of Cape Bishop and if Hawkeye
strany from the comics ever
shows up on the big screen you could be
like ya got back card and the app has a
program called first printing kind of
like how comic book editions are printed
based on demand it's just a very cool
take on a classic Hobby experience we
here at new rock stars are also working
with tops to do a special giveaway
contest that I will talk about later on
in this breakdown okay moving on to and
over sentimental tribute montage to the
Fallen of endgame Tony Stark Natasha
Romanov vision also to Whitney Houston's
I will always love you it's interesting
that cap was included here considering
he survived the battle with this return
trip back to the 40s and agent into
Clint Eastwood the general public must
have assumed that he didn't make it
either wait he's not part of the world
anymore I like the diesel that since
this montage was edited by high school
students some of the images have Getty
Images watermarks on them this tribute
is on the Midtown Morning News again
hosted by Betty Brant and Jason Aiello
they recount their take on thanasis snap
and infinity war and Hulk's snap back an
endgame a five-year period that they're
now referring to as the blip much better
name my opinion and they show up with
video footage of the marching band
dusting but then returning five years
later mid basketball game one of those
band members didn't nailed some of the
music that we hear in these opening
minutes is a track by composer Michael
Giacchino son Mick Giacchino a film
musician in his own right and the track
is titled if you're snappy and you know
it lover
Betty and Jason mentioned how kids
younger than them are now their age or
older including Brad Davis a wimp turned
hunk and in my opinion the true villain
of far from home hashtag be Brad he's
played by Remmy he and the comics Brad
Davis was the name of the football
player who date's Mary Jane Watson Betty
says it's time for them to move on which
has got to be a nod to the move on that
we've quoted way too much in the months
before and game some people move on and
let us move on to Peter and Ned now
their classroom is lined with Ironman
tribute art art that shows up all over
the world of this film yet no art for
Black Widow Peter mentions his plan to
win over MJ including by in her glass
jewelry in Venice in the shape of a
Black Dahlia her favorite flower
which is a reference to the famous black
dahlia murder case in LA in 1947 very
grisly but also in the Marvel Comics The
Black Dahlia czar also
name of a female street gang who protect
women from violence Peter appears that
Aunt May's charity event for the
homeless which could be a nod to feast
the homeless relief organization from
the spider-man comics and games happy
Hogan shows up without nice big check
from Stark Industries signed by Pepper
Potts suggesting that life is moving on
with pepper still in charge of Tony's
company and charity foundations but in
the background is an old wrestling
poster listing crusher Hogan which is
the name of the wrestler that Peter
Parker faced in the exhibition match
back in his comic book origin and
actually on that same poster beneath
crusher Hogan is the name bone saw
McGraw which is the name of the wrestler
character that Macho Man Randy Savage
played in the Sam Raimi spider-man
exhibition match the director mixing
comic references and former film
adaptations in the MCU like this sets up
the bigger Sam Raimi Eric Hall back in a
post-credits scene of course with JK
Simmons returning as J jonah Jameson
Peter goes back out to face fans and
press now the framing of this shot seems
like a nod to the famous panel of Peter
from the Civil War comics the moment
Peter unmasked himself to the public to
support Starks push for superhero
registration but this also foreshadows
far from homes twist in the mid credit
scene with Peter finally being outed to
the public Peter looks at this tribute
mural of Iron Man which is another
example of the stark art littered all
over this movie one theory that I liked
is that some of this street art in the
New York area could have been done by
Miles Morales now he would be in
Brooklyn not Queens but we know from the
aaron davis scene homecoming that miles
does exist somewhere in the MCU peter
packs were his Eurotrip in a suitcase
has the initials BF p meaning that the
suitcase probably belonged to his late
uncle Ben Parker whom was modeled after
American founding father Benjamin
Franklin meaning that his middle name
also reflects his inspiration it made
Chuck's a banana at Peter the same Adana
that she later sneaks into his luggage
with the spider-man suit
she thinks that his spidey sense or as
it is called in this movie his Peter
tingle will alert him to it but it
doesn't work now this is a subtle detail
and far from home but Peter left
infinity war an endgame with an anxiety
over his spidey sense or Peter tingle
because if you remember the moments
before he dusted away on tightening his
spidey sense for warned him of his
coming death making his death way more
nauseating and drawn-out than the other
hero's deaths were and for him that
feeling is all tied in with the pain of
lose
mr. stark but despite the Associated
trauma Peters tingle is the one form of
perception that makes him unique to
normal people he's got spidey sense you
can see danger before it comes far from
home is a film about perception versus
deception and Peters journey here is to
overcome his fear of his own
supernatural perception so that he can
see through the smokescreen of deception
and defeat the evil on the flight Peters
attempted to swap seats around to sit
beside MJ into them stuck beside mr.
Harrington who tells them that his wife
pretended to blip out faking her death
to leave him and sad and hilarious but
it's also another reminder of the
deception concept of this film and as
Peter learns later with Mysterio when
people die or appear to be dying you
can't always believe what you see in
this world on the in-flight movie screen
are a few MCU Easter eggs movie titles
showing the snap with an image of
thanasis gauntlet finding Wakanda
hunting Hydra and Nova einstein-rosen
bridges with dr. Erik Selvig of course
is the astrophysicist from the Thor
movies now an einstein-rosen bridge is
another name for a wormhole and this
room actually came up in Thor Ragnarok
when Banner was describing the devil's
anus but Nova is also the name of a
Marvel superhero a member of the Nova
Corps that we saw in guardians a galaxy
and Kevin Feige has hinted that Nova
could get his own movie in the future
and then Peter swipes overdone another
title part of iron the Tony Stark's
story Peter once again unable to escape
the painful memory of losing mr. stark
despite the fact that as soon as he
gleams in Venice more stark art will
haunt him while touring the Venetian
canals there was a shot in the trailers
that might not have been included in the
final cut of the movie with Ned passing
a boat number 8 sm 2 1/2 a nod to the
amazing spider-man issued to 12 which
was the introduction of Hydra man now
Hydra man of the comics is Morrie bench
whose name and origin actually get a
shout-out later when the students
research details on BuzzFeed about the
water monster but again these actual
Spider Man villain Easter eggs are mr. X
designed to make us doubt Beks whole
explanation now after the big showdown
with the water elemental and Mysterio
and the Grand Canal of which of course
later revealed to be a hoax it may call
speeder asking if Beck was mr. strains
feeding up the great running joke of how
goofy dr. Strange's name is Doctor
Strange
mr. doctor mr. doctor
it's strange maybe the kids watch the
news coverage of Quentin Beck whom Brad
describes as Iron Man Thor rolled into
one
do you Brad and they derived the moniker
of Mysterio from the Italian news
description Rome OD mr. o or man of
mystery Nick Fury shows up and tranqs
Ned and they head to a hidden base to
talk now fury says stark told him to
tell him uneasy lies the head that wears
the crown
which is a quote from Shakespeare's
Henry the fourth part - not a Star Wars
reference and if you think about is
actually an older incarnation of with
great power comes great responsibility
fury gives Peter Tony Starks sunglasses
which we saw Tony wearing an affinity
worn in-game now these magic glasses are
the key magic item of this story they
are a symbol of Tony Stark's legacy and
a reflection of the perception versus
deception theme that I've been
discussing by inheriting these glasses
Peter is meant to take on the torch of
Tony Stark's gifted perception to see
through all the [ __ ] of the world
like Peter later in this film
Tony's site once caused him to suffer
from terrifying nightmares
hallucinations Peter doesn't want that
responsibility but he realizes that he's
the only trustworthy hands of that power
there are some parallels between far
from home and the Wizard of Oz the
classic story of perception and illusion
Mysterio really is an adaptation of the
Great and Powerful oz a wizard with the
dome head and colorful smoke who is
revealed to be nothing more than a
charlatan a man behind the curtain and
actually in el frank Baum's original
novel people in the Emerald City are
given green tinted spectacles to wear to
precede everything in the color green
which at the time was like a loaded
political commentary that green paper
currency was actually valueless and I'm
not gonna get into the history of it but
here the concept is the inverse the man
behind the curtain has deceived everyone
with his green smoke screen and Peter
needs the tricked-out spectacles to see
through the eyes
Peter officially meets Quentin Beck who
along with fury claims to be from
another dimension
mr. Beck is from Earth just not yours
there are multiple realities Peter this
is earth to mention 6-1-6 I'm from Earth
II
three okay there's a lot to him back
there the numbers Beck is using are
references to the Marvel multiverse in
the comics a vast infinite number of
parallel realities the primary reality
in the comics is called earth-616 which
actually showed up as an easter egg in
avengers endgame as the number on Scott
Lang storage unit six one six was also
the number of Peter Parker's original
universe and into the spider-verse earth
eight three three in the comics is the
reality in which spider-man is a British
kid named Billy graddic who becomes spy
during UK but for Marvel nerds like us
hearing Mysterio claim this to be
earth-616 should raise some red flags
because the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has always been technically identified
as earth one nine nine nine nine nine
that's five nines right so when we heard
this we thought whoa Marvel might be
trying to redefine things but more
likely mysterious just too big that liar
which he is but also fury just gave a
tell of his own he told Peter that this
earth was yours even say ours we learned
the post-credits scene that this Nick
Fury is actually the Skrull shapeshifter
Talos from Captain Marvel and alien who
is not from Earth and this is just the
first of many clues pointing to his true
identity I've acted at the in the movie
he just says appearances can be
deceiving mmm smoking gun back shows
projections of interdimensional rifts
and his alternate earth explaining how
these creatures that he calls elementals
destroyed his planet killed his family
he sadly rubs his ring he says the myths
are true and Peter just eats it up he's
like that's how Thor works I guess these
work the same way look folks maybe I've
just watched too many movies but this
whole backstory just sounds so Hollywood
II in cliche now sure elementals are
characters in the Marvel Comics but
they're different their doctor trains
and they wear weird stuff but like Fifth
Element aside any time air earth water
and fire show up and some kind of cosmic
significance folks those four are not
scientific elements it's just they were
important to the ancient Greeks so when
it's brought up in the scientific
context it should definitely make us
skeptical Peter asks if other Avengers
gonna help don't involve me it's kind of
weird for Fury to say this right and for
that matter for Talos to say this
because last time we saw all of them
they're all eating dinner on great terms
perhaps that is tied into Fury's weird
mission in space with the scrolls and
the post-credits scene talk more about
that later Peter is group re rounded on
a bus driven by Dmitry through the Alps
the license plate is MK 6224 are L not
sure if that means anything
there's a couple other license plates on
buses that I couldn't hide anything
specifically but maybe they are and on
this bus Peter puts on Tony's glasses
where he meets Edith an acronym from
Starke meaning even dead I'm the hero
now wearing these Peter can snoop on
what everyone is doing on their phones
the chaperone mr. Dell JD smooth is
looking of the history of witchcraft
since he believes the incident in Venice
was due to which is interestingly you
can also see that Flash Thompson is
texting his mom mother I have not heard
from you or father in days which doesn't
seem like a big deal to the end of the
movie when they return and flash asks
his driver could mother not make it no
response
[Music]
yeah something must be in the works with
Flash's mother for maybe the third film
in the comics Flash's mom Rosie Thompson
is the wife of an NYPD officer Harrison
Thompson who is an abusive alcoholic
movies could go in this direction but
Flash's wealth in these movies suggests
a different home life to me perhaps the
MCU will whet Khan his mother to have
the name of Norman Osborn after Peter
picks up his new stealth suit he knocks
out abuse victim flash maybe and he
nearly kills Brad with a drone the group
arrives in Prague where Peter ditches
them at the Opera to help Quentin back
defeat the fire elemental during the
festival now there's actually another
easter egg on the license plate of Nick
Fury's car says ASM 28 965 which is a
nod to amazing spider-man number 28
released in September the 9th month year
in 1965 this was the introduction of
molten man whom like the fire elemental
here is based on a liquid metal alloy
Peter embed get a victory drink in a
nearby bar where the jambs town called
malice is plain now this 1981 song was
featured prominently in another famous
Eurotrip movie National Lampoon's
European vacation Anna was featured in
the 2000 film Billy Elliot the plays
stage musical version of which gave Tom
Holland his first big break did I force
that trivia point and kinda Peter
decides to give back the start glasses
shirking his responsibilities and he
leaves and then the bar patrons and
decor fade away as projections and in a
very exposition packed victory speech
Quentin Beck reveals his secret evil
plot so it turns out Beck leads a group
of former Stark Industries engineers who
feel spurned by Starks mistreatment and
spurned by his decision to give Edith to
spider-man not to them so they combine
their resources to create projected
illusions of elemental monsters that
Quentin Beck and swoop in and defeat
playing the media
to become the new Ironman Beck reveals
that he invented barf the binary
augmented retro framing tech that Tony
showed off in civil war is now using the
same hollow projections to trick the
world and naturally he hates a Tony
called apart from although I think we
all love it
Beck's team parallels the production
crew of a player whom he is a director
and lead actor his director of
photography or visual effects artist
it's William Gunter Reva a cameo
callback all the way back from Iron Man
he was a guy who opened eyes Dane
shootout fun fact William is played by
Peter Billingsley longtime collaborator
with Jon Favreau and producer in the
first Ironman and it's a kid
he played Ralphie in a Christmas story
this crew also includes a guy
responsible for the narrative and
backstory of Quentin Beck he would be
the screenwriter in this metaphor
there's a woman who stages electrical
impulses to fool Nick Fury she would be
something like the location scout and
there's a woman who informed them all
that Edith was going to someone else she
would probably be the equivalent of an
ancient who keeps the talent aware of
where opportunities are going and when
it's not going to them later this woman
doubles as a costumer steaming
mysterious Cape later you can see all of
them rehearsing with Starks drones with
Beck now wearing a motion capture suit
and this is the exact same kind that
these Marvel actors wear when they're
super forms get CGI painted over them
and post Peter goes on to mark with MJ
where she reveals that she kind of
already deduced that he was spider-man
and they discover from a broken piece of
Beck's Hollow Tech what he has been up
to then in Berlin Nick Fury picks up
Peter in a car with the license plate
MTU 83 779 which is a nod to Marvel
team-up 83 released in July 1979 in this
issue Nick Fury and Peter Parker team up
as they do in the scene or do they
because this meeting is a grand illusion
by Mysterio quite the clever ambush -
because he initially shows Fury reacting
to Maria hill fading away all to trick
Peter with another layer of trust since
fury picked him up so that Peter would
be more willing to confess to fury later
on who else he told about this and this
illusion montage is just one of the most
visually stunning sequences yet in the
MCU as Mysterio has done the comics he
projects imagery to manipulate Peter
freaking out glutton and won't point
making himself up here giant-sized but
this is filled with interesting imagery
and callbacks like there's a projection
of his high school moving on to the
observation
decade' I felt our with MJ where he
intended on wooing her but then it
transforms into a Hall of Mirrors
arranged to form in Sierra's justa
effect leading to multiple spider-men
tackling him and then Peter finds
himself on a stone floor with an action
of Captain America star shield and then
he reverts to his original DIY sweatsuit
costume from homecoming then he finds
himself at the grave of Tony Stark
Starks gauntlet burst out of the grave
same hand that he snapped with and then
Peter stuck inside his snow globe with
Avengers tower a globe that becomes
Mysterio's helmet and then after
accidentally confessing a Mysterio who
else knows Peter gets hit by a train
wakes up in a jail cell with some
friendly Dutch dudes then joins make up
with happy hogan now on the jet peter
designs a new suit with Starks tech
among the Holograms are alternate suit
designs including what looks like the
mk2 spider armor and the recent ps4 game
suit Peter inserts his arm in the
hologram lifts it up like a gauntlet
makes happy smile because this is
exactly what Tony Stark did when
designing his armor in the first Iron
Man movie and to complete this
comparison happy plays a cdc's back in
black the theme music from the first
film and Peter goes I love Led Zepplin
he gets wrong but he's still had to love
it meanwhile fury mentions to Hill
something about Kree sleeper cells
before they get interrupted another clue
that they actually Scrolls in the size
and this could mean that in the present
day the Kree in the scroll are still at
war and that the Kree in addition to the
scroll may be implanted around the world
with their own spy network with sleeper
cells then everything moves to London
for the final act Mysterio uses Edith
and Starks drones to attack the students
on Tower Bridge happy calls fury giving
them a coded message about him needing
to pick up his surfboard could be just a
throwaway line or it could be a nod to a
possible Silver Surfer movie an MCU
future
please cast Keanu Reeves on Tower Bridge
the license plates contain more Easter
eggs there's an audio with the plate
number 2865 SCP 2065 probably another
nod to molten man but later there's a
car flipped upside down the plate
reading tas m14 3 or the amazing
spider-man issue 143 the issue where
spider-man fights cyclone similar to the
elemental in this battle Peter dives
from Happy's jet into the belly of the
beast
literally webbing up all the drones
projecting this hologram and later
electrifying them which is them using
the Taser web function revealed at
homecoming
during the battle the drones hit Peter
with a shockwave it's actually a sonic
cannon the same kind that were you
the Hulk in the incredible hole Peter
returns to his DIY roots and engineers a
solution using car parts plus the
explosive core of a scavenged drone to
make a kind of mace plus he grabs the
tower bridge sign to make a shield
now these melee weapons make Peter look
a lot like cap when he carried both his
shield and Neal near an endgame and
Peter in this medieval knight formation
also brings him full circle with the
moment Tony Stark made him an Avenger an
infinity war he knighted him on each
shoulder during this battle happy and
some of the teens flee and dude the
Tower of London for the crown jewels are
kept and I like how as they run in wats
include a shot of the Queen's card
firing assault rifles at the drones just
reminder that these guards are in real
life
serious badasses should definitely not
look around with them happy pics of an
old shielding tries to frisbee it at a
drone fails miserably yes how does cap
do that meanwhile Peter confronts Beck
on the upper level of tower bridge and
when Mysterio tries once again to trap
him in a loose nation Peter covers his
eyes of blinders Blindy and his normal
physical senses but finally trusting his
own Peter tingle sense the Spidey one to
guide him giving him the unique
perception to cut right through
Mysterio's deception both with the
drones and later with Mysterio trying to
sneak up on him and shoot him in the
head god if you think about this blind
native oneself is similar to Daniel's
son using the blindfold and kradic kid
to kick Johnny's ass so Peter regains
Edith or deserts who executes all the
drones the audio of which Beck and
William will later used to frame Peter
as the true villain and it credits scene
as Quentin Beck breathes his final
breaths he says people need something to
believe in these days they'll believe
anything pretty chilling final words
with back even in death embracing the
deception principle that Peters
perception has defeated or has it
many are wondering rightly how Peter
could have so easily reacquired Edith
since remember he had to basically
reboot her and hand her off to Beck
earlier Beck definitely didn't do that
for Peter so could Beck have rigged
Edith to perform one last deception on
Peter into thinking he's dead we did
learn earlier that Edith stands for even
dead I'm the hero which is in effect
what Mysterio does after his death
paints himself as the hero so what if in
addition to stark that acronym applies
to Mysterio as seemingly dead presence
whose threat will only grow from beyond
the grave
so they return home in the final
sequence shows Peter [ __ ]
swinging through New York you look
closely he passes through what was once
Avengers Tower but now it kind of has a
mid-level atrium suggest you some new
ownership
could it be Oscorp could it be the back
stability of the Fantastic Four we will
see and then when he swings down the MJ
there's a sign in the Far background
with a timeline of arrows pointing to
the right numbers one two and three and
then a question mark with the words we
are excited to show you what comes next
which is a nod to far from home being
the official end of Marvel phase 3 in
what comes next in phase four soon to be
revealed the mid-credits scene features
JK Simmons returning to stay jonah
Jameson from the Sam Raimi spider-man
movies now running a Daily Bugle that's
less of a print tabloid and more of an
infamous how website and broadcast his
big scoop is Mysterio's fake video
spider-man Emma stirs reveal of Peters
identity and so with a battle between
perception and deception continues maybe
now with Peter having to do the
deceiving now there's one final Easter
egg in the final post-credit scene on
fury in hills car or is it a lesson
saurons car the license plate reads H in
m6 2011 which is a nod to the comic
Hawkeye and Mockingbird number six which
was released in 2011 which features Nick
Fury in scroll form as he is in this
scene as for what the real Nick Fury is
doing up in space so that he would need
tailless and Sauron to shape-shift into
him and Maria hill down on earth my
thing is that fury could be doing an MCU
version of sword which is a counterpart
organisation of shield as things are in
the marble timeline right now the shield
is kind of a mess so that would make
sense but what do you think fury is up
to and do you think Mysterio could it
faked his death comment down below with
your thoughts and thank you again to
Marvel collect bye tops for sponsoring
this breakdown Marvel collect is the app
that lets you collect and trade digital
trading cards with an ever-expanding
collection of content from the Marvel
Universe and again the app is free to
download free to play and I like how it
lets you track your progress to complete
sets like you can tap on a card to find
out how to get your hands on it or if
it's sold out what users have that card
so you can try to trade for it and it
gives you lots of different ways to
build up buying power daily login bonus
ah's and these cool collector based
missions which keep you on track with
daily and weekly goals to earn currency
in the
and use that to open digital packs of
cards and we got a special bonus just
for you guys so the folks at tops were
super nice to send me this Infinity
Gauntlet and we also have one that we're
gonna give away to one of you in a
special giveaway contest you can enter
to win the gauntlet just by clicking on
the other link in the description and
then on that site all you got to do just
follow the steps and you will be entered
for that Infinity Gauntlet plus a larger
grand prize drawing with the opportunity
to win an iPhone 10 or a samsung s9 can
I enter this contest I want one of those
so anyway jump on this giveaway and
remember you can download marvel collect
buy tops with our download link in the
description or find out in the iTunes
app store or in the Google Play Store
worldwide follow me on instagram and
twitter at EA vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns of theories
about everything marvel thank you for
joining me and hey actor Remy he you
were great and far from home no hard
feelings but it comes to the character
that you played you Brad
[Music]